well well well reject nation greg and
john here today
last night was the highly anticipated
fight between floyd
money mayweather and logan paul and i
watched the whole thing
paid top dollar for it that's right
i totally paid uh
the money the fee for that vod yeah yeah
i so did pay-per-view you supported
logan paul
and floyd mayweather both of whom needed
one support 100
i did this absolutely you did not a
dollar wasted then the fight went almost
exactly like how a lot of people
predicted it would go
and uh it didn't end in the way how a
lot of people were kind of hoping it
would end
where floyd mayweather who's not known
for his knockouts
we were still hoping he would knock him
out
he didn't but logan paul has really
earned his way
fighting floyd mayweather hasn't hey
we're gonna watch the best memes today
yesterday i was on social media i'm like
the most entertaining thing about this
whole fight is
all the crap people are saying online
and the commentators during the fight
made it so much more entertaining let's
watch this and see how it goes
cool
[Laughter]
oh
oh it's gonna be manly hugging memes
isn't it
hey man he looked tired early on and he
kept going
very true classic meme template
we should all be so lucky
he's old right yeah we knew what he was
doing he could have won
he was just chilling he didn't even
practice
it's an actual picture from the
these words
more fun than a pillow fight
oh they walked right into that one
after the first time logan paul got hit
like really hard in the face he looked
like a little out of it for the rest of
the match
[Laughter]
yeah it says i think it's that ferocious
photoshop that's beautiful
oh dude good old we boxing
oh that's an immortal shot he was
just they kept cutting to him
we've all been there
wow nice every time
[Laughter]
oh okay go
i i bet that's a real feel
i mean you just kept dodging
is that real no okay yeah fake tweet
right
good old free hugs
[Laughter]
that'd be awesome he's earned that too
you're not tired that's what they cut
them at one point trainer saying that
oh no
it's about it's about everybody walked
out of this fight for the worse
oh oh snap
just
oh god cynthia
i love all the naked spongebobs in this
compilation
logan paul is [ __ ] spongebob i think
at one point the comment they cut to
jake paul i don't think the commentators
directly said shut up but it felt like
they were telling him to shut up at one
point i think you guys if you watched it
you would you know
what moment i'm talking about just
starts yelling at the camera but yeah
man that fight was not uh
it did just to the hype it just wasn't
entertaining to me you know like i am on
the side of why is this guy here i get
it's an exhibition match but i bet
i bet it like just pisses off real
athletes and boxers who
who have really trained tirelessly to
get to this point and left or they can
fight a champion you know oh yeah and
you got a youtuber here like yeah they
were really the commentators are really
ripping into him that you could tell me
they actually i don't say
i'm gonna say rip it i thought they were
holding back a little bit but you know
they did not like the fact that that guy
was in the ring with floyd mayweather
there was someone who said like yeah
what's gonna happen is floyd's really
gonna let this play
out he's not gonna knock him out he's
gonna give some props to him
at the end of the match you know cause
like floyd mayweather was even like
he's damned if he knocks him out because
people will be mad that fight's so short
yeah and then he's damned if he doesn't
because then people are like man he's
just a youtuber you should have knocked
him out
so floyd mayweather was just like you
could tell there's such a difference in
fighting because floyd miller looked
like he was having
a fun time except for the couple times
he looked genuinely provoked there was a
couple
most of the fighting his stamina is
still so good and he just looks like
he's having fun there's times where he's
just smiling
like logan paul he tired his way through
it so i'll give him credit for at least
uh still being on his toes during the
whole time
and uh for not getting knocked out i
would i would say because he
did look uh extremely tired very early
on in the fight looking back at the ksi
fight it's like yeah i can see why you
would lend some credence to that because
these are two guys who are sort of
at least trying their hands at this but
yeah and they're also in the same field
yeah so it's like we can all kind of
come down to this level there's
something amusing about it
yeah it's like where you get this chance
that like so many other fighters have
like dreamt of dedicated their lives to
it
yeah just because you mess around on the
internet now you can come out here
like yeah i can understand why anybody
would be upset and why commentators
wouldn't want to cut that slack like
they would in a ksi fight or something
like that this uh
this watching the fight just made me go
wasn't it like a couple of years ago
where this guy looked like he was on the
verge of being canceled for that whole
japanese forest situation and people
want to act like cancel culture really
gets the job done every time i'm like
this guy's fighting floyd mayweather
you're getting paid millions of dollars
to do it right now that's the brilliant
thing about him transitioning into
boxing because everyone wants to see him
get punched that's
the way he can make money doing that
it's he's beating us at our own game
yeah he's smart he knows what he's doing
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
pandemic jones paul pj man of many names
i wanted to dedicate this shout out to
you because if there's anyone who
probably wants to punch me
i think it's you and i bet you know why
because now there are two olivia rodrigo
music videos out that i haven't gotten a
chance to see but don't you worry bud
i'm gonna give you a double feature at
some point and if i don't then you and
me we can step into the ring i'll do my
hand one hand tied behind my back and
then you can you know beat the heck out
of me on the internet we can live
stream it sell some tickets or whatnot
you know what's his first name
paul you know you could have done logan
paul like you know jake paul wants to
fight him but you're the paul who can
actually take down mayweather
you are the pawn tied it into making it
about you and your
ways of disappointing people i just
wanted to make it
something that we share which is due
disappointing well yeah that's exactly
it man i wanted to kill him
uplifting
you are the best you ruined it